he's hot
blowing the pins in five
hallo the Master Chief collection is one
game but four halos that means four full
campaigns four games worth of
competitive multiplayer and a whole
bunch of Forge to boot it's a lot and as
a pure bang for your buck proposition
it's hard not to recommend jumping back
into a campaign is like traveling back
in time or opening a time capsule
depending on your age it takes a while
to get your bearings but once you're
dialed in all the thrills of yesteryear
come rushing back romping through levels
with a friend taking on the fierce
challenge of legendary difficulty
loading up that one level just to mess
around with vehicles all of these joys
are well preserved competitive
multiplayer is a different story once
you're in a playlist for a given game
and have gotten the hang of which pistol
you're using these matches can channel
the excitement and tension that so many
have enjoyed over the years
unfortunately serious matchmaking
problems make this scenario all but
unattainable as of this review developer
343 industries is working diligently to
get everything up and running but it's
unclear how long it will be until all
the included multiplayer options are
readily available and how many players
will stick around that long to populate
matches
these issues make the Master Chief
collection much more difficult to
recommend but there's still a lot to
enjoy here especially in Master Chief's
for galaxy spanning adventures between
them they span eleven years of Halo
demand to jump between campaigns is to
do a kind of developer assisted time
travel you're not changing controllers
or swapping discs and all the missions
are unlocked from the get-go so you're
free to mix and match easily from the
clear intuitive menus or use one of the
preset playlists that does the mixing
and matching for you it's a novel
feeling to have so much halo laid out
before you and the crisp organization of
it all serves as a great template for
other series that might dare to assemble
collections of their own and yet for all
the logistical smoothness there's a
certain shock in transitioning between
the campaigns it's not just the visual
differences though those are striking
even with the two remastered anniversary
editions it's the movement speed the
weapon handling the cadence of combat
the flow of level design the dramatic
pacing all of these elements varies
significantly between the four campaigns
getting recalibrated is a strange
sometimes bumpy sensation even if you've
played all these games before let's
start with halo combat Evolved
Anniversary I reviewed this game three
years ago for GameSpot and rated it an
eight and you know what it's still great
the story of what happened when humanity
found a halo is still an intriguing one
and even though you can feel Master
Chief's age in his measure of movement
speed the combat systems have an
internal consistency that make them
great fun to play around with once
you've gotten your touchpad unlike in
the Xbox 360 release switching between
original and anniversary visuals is now
instantaneous and though the updated
environments are much more lush and
appealing than the old ones it's really
cool to see how well a lot of the
architectural design holds its sense of
alienness and foreboding all these years
later
perhaps the most notable entry in the
Master Chief collection is a low -
anniversary as it's the first appearance
of this legendary yet somewhat
contentious sequel in its remastered
form the immediate standout is the new
cutscenes done by the halo 4 cutscene
folks at blur studios who are just
phenomenal the new videos look gorgeous
and though they cover the same dialogue
they do so with a flair for
cinematography that the originals lacked
they even made the confusing visual
debacle of the grave mind look sinister
and powerful and toothy and gross look
so good the anniversary visuals
themselves looked pretty great too
especially in the earthbound levels
where the original visual design was a
bit more pedestrian switching between
the two instantly is a delight though
sticking with the anniversary look often
rewards you with environmental details
that simply weren't there before however
you'll also have to contend with more
extremes of light and dark the blinding
barrage of enemy artillery can
completely whiteout your screen while
the dark corners of buildings might make
you reach for your remote to up your
TV's brightness or switch to the
original visuals in hopes of
understanding where exactly you are
there are a few oddities in the
remastered audio as well
Miranda Keys sounds like she just took a
rip off a helium balloon yes sir though
honestly that's probably my memories of
Halo 3 Keys interfering because she
actually sounds similarly tinny in the
original Halo 2 cutscenes a few of the
updated weapon sounds made me yearn for
the originals but remastered visuals are
always paired with remastered sound so
there's no splitting the difference the
Brasher new SMG sounds disappointed me
personally but the new orchestration is
so good that I usually just stuck with
the remastered presentation
if we can Helmand sergeant extract the
chief and return to an Amber clad Roger
halo 3 is still pretty fantastic though
you'll likely wish blurr had taken a
whack at it when you see the original
cutscenes regardless of the lack of
remastering the game still looks pretty
solid given that it came out seven years
ago got a mold but the real joy of
playing halo 3 is the feeling that this
is the halo when Bungie really nailed
what halo was all about not just
designing levels that flow between
diverse areas in a pleasing cadence not
just making vehicles available on levels
that are playable on foot as well and
not just giving you a powerful yet
simple array of combat tools
what halo 3 does really well is
frequently create situations where you
have significant choice about how to
approach a combat scenario this
flexibility which was present to a
lesser degree in the previous games
allows playing solo playing co-op
playing on a harder difficulty playing
with skull modifiers on to all feel like
different endeavors you're not just
using your solo normal difficulty
strategies and executing them better
instead you're attempting daring stunts
when you're feeling confident and you're
experimenting with different approaches
when you're feeling overwhelmed halo 3
cultivates these moments and as a result
it feels like a challenge and it feels
like a playground which are some of the
best feelings that video games can
create
playing Halo 4 in the context of the
first Halo trilogy is to reinforce how
much it feels like a new chapter for the
series it's kind of shifting of gears
literally because Master Chief can now
sprint and narrative Lee because there
are new characters introduced and new
lore delved into with dialogue character
development and cinematography that is
the best the series had seen so far it
is distinctly of this era of gaming and
requires the least recalibration for
folks who have been keeping relatively
current with their shooters the
modernization of Master Chief's combat
mechanics doesn't sweep away the
traditional series strengths which are
still prominent here but rather it
updates them and makes him feel like a
proper super soldier only he's not the
only super soldier around anymore and
hearing people treat him with something
less than utter reverence signals the
start of a new trilogy as much as any
gameplay update or new enemy type
this new trilogy progressing next year
with a planned release of Halo 5
guardians also appears in other places
in the Master Chief collection entirely
new cutscenes for Halo 2 and a number of
new terminals to be found cover events
that will presumably become relevant in
a future release voiced as they are by
agent Locke the new protagonists for
Halo 5 these help contribute to the
cohesiveness of the collection as a
whole and engender the sense that this
nostalgic package is also
forward-looking
so there's a ton of action to sink your
energy sword into on the campaign side
and the same should be true for the
multiplayer side with four games worth
of competitive combat including both
classic and anniversary maps for Halo
two as well as halo combat Evolved
original action online on console for
the first time there's a lot of arenas
and game modes to get into combat
evolves vicious pistol halo 2's dual
wielding halo threes equipment and Halo
4's armor abilities are some of the
major differentiators but there are a
host of other mechanics balance tweaks
and visual changes that make each era
distinct hopping between them can feel
like a kind of whiplash but the through
lines that have kept Halo multiplayer
near the top of the heap shine through
diverse map design great vehicles and
versatile weapons all contribute to an
ever-shifting combat dynamic in which
your best strategy one minute might be
you're worse than next there's always
something you can do better when you
outmaneuver a tough opponent it's
sublime satisfaction at its best the
Master Chief collection is able to
recreate these moments but as of this
review it almost never does
getting into an online match can take
upwards of 10 minutes if it even works
at all once you're in you're often
confronted with lopsided teams and small
player count at the end of the match
you're usually left hanging on the
postgame report not put into a lobby to
join another match backing out and
re-entering a playlist sometimes causes
the game to crash it's a mess and the
developers have removed playlist options
while they work to issue improvements to
get this thing back on track despite
their frequent progress updates it's
unclear how long these issues will
persist when the full slate of playlists
will be restored and how many players
will be around to populate matches once
everything is in order
reviving and remastering campaigns is a
tricky endeavor and the Master Chief
collection has done so with aplomb
trying to recapture a multiplayer
audience is an even trickier proposition
and serious launch problems are a
serious blow to the collections
ambitions as a way to relive the
grandeur and mayhem of halos campaigns
the Master Chief collection excels but
when it comes to recapturing the thrills
of its online competition it has a long
long way to go
you